the One Piece manga just revealed
something about the world of one piece
and its history that will change how we
see the story forever because as it
turns out Egghead Island the island with
the most insane technology on the entire
planet is not the island of the future
after all instead vegapunk explains that
his research lab is actually a place of
the past his technology is pale in
comparison to the technological
advancements made by the legendary
ancient Kingdom that was destroyed
during the void century and we see Luffy
discovering what seems to be a gigantic
ancient robot outside the lab and so
there are five incredibly important
things that we can take away from all of
this like the fact that we now know for
certain that one piece is a story taking
place in a post-apocalyptical world
which is absolutely crazy but where did
Oda get the idea for this this reveal
feels a lot like the one in Attack on
Titan where you get fed one narrow
perspective of what this world is like
until you find find out that nothing is
what it seems that is the exact same
feeling I have here turns out the world
of One Piece as we know it is the
cataclysmic aftermath of an era of
greatness that came beforehand the first
thing that came to my mind right away
here is The Wheel of Time in case you're
not familiar with the story it's a
fantasy novel that takes place in the
medieval Lord of the Rings like world in
the third age after the so-called
breaking of the worlds now even though
it's not a major plot Point throughout
the story the author feeds the reader
hints that the world before this
breaking was actually our own reality
that Humanity became incredibly advanced
in the future and ultimately destroyed
itself leading to a complete setback and
a world that feels like fantasy that's
exactly The Vibes that I'm getting from
all this in one piece as well right now
and I can't really begin to tell you
just how great a piece of writing this
is it makes the lore and story of one
piece even better than it already was
the love Oda has for aliens and sci-fi
stories like Star Wars have also gotten
really apparent in the recent chapters I
think and the giant Mossy robot from a
last ancient civilization has pretty
strong Castle in the Sky vipes a Ghibli
movie that seems to have a number of
connections with one piece really go
watch it if you haven't it's fantastic
but it's not only fiction that Oda was
inspired by here because there are
multiple theories out there that our own
real world experienced a similar setback
as well people like Graham Hancock or
Randall Carlson argued that the last ice
age started and ended with a cataclysmic
catastrophe that might have wiped out an
already advanced ancient civilization
from the face of our own Planet roughly
12 000 years ago lost to the Sea as sea
levels Rose over 80 meters in the
aftermath it speculated that this
ancient civilization was the one that
built the pyramids all around the world
and mapped the entire planet now I'm
neither an archaeologist nor a geologist
so I really can't evaluate how accurate
the signs on all of this is but there
seems to be increasing evidence for it
and in any case it doesn't really matter
to us here if it's true or not because
it's an incredibly fun and interesting
topic to go down the rabbit hole for and
due to all the similarities these
theories have with oda's writing I'm 99
convinced that Oda took inspiration from
this Theory as well which brings me to
the second point on my list what does
this major reveal mean for the one piece
world and the context of the story well
we now pretty much know that there used
to be modern day technology on the
planet including space travel and
advanced Computing but then at some
point this Advanced civilization got
defeated by the 20 kingdoms that later
became the world government that is
ruling the world until today after this
war a major technological setback
happened throwing the world back into
the age of guns and swords and seafaring
and it also explains really nicely now
why the world government was so keen on
wiping any trace of this Kingdom from
the history books if anyone were to find
out the truth about their Advanced
civilization well they could try and
find and revive its technology and use
it against the government and so emu and
tagoro say are purposefully withholding
this knowledge and banning any research
on it to keep their subjects unaware and
incapable of standing up against their
tyrannical Rule now you might be
wondering why that is such a big deal
after all there were many hints already
in the story that the ancient kingdom
was quite powerful so what really has
changed with this reveal what's the fact
that what Luffy finds is a giant
functioning Titanic robot and until this
point we all kind of assumed that much
in the one piece world is kind of based
on the story's own magic system like
chakra or something devil fruits have a
literal devil in them the ancient
weapons are just unique abilities
certain people have and the ancient
Kingdom build big cities yeah like wano
and shandora and we're a place where
everyone could live together in harmony
but that's kind of it technology wise
made me similar to the level of ancient
Greece or something like that if he
wants but with this reveal that all of
the Fantastic technology that Oda has
shown Us in vegapunk's lab so far that
all of that is not even on the same
level as the ancient Kingdom used to be
this tells us that we're talking Star
Wars level civilization instead of
ancient Rome here and I think that's
absolutely insane it means that the
entire power system in one piece might
very well be science after all as you
know science that is Advanced enough
does look like magic if you're
unfamiliar with it it means that devil
fruits could simply be a technology and
not some sort of power system it also
means that the ancient weapons to me at
least suddenly become a much more
terrifying and graspable threat as well
I mean think Death Star something that
can destroy entire planets I explained
how much Oda loves Star Wars in the last
chapter review where he introduced a
lightsaber into the story as well pluton
B being buried in the volcano under wano
could therefore be some apocalyptic
giant machine with unfathomable Powers I
think the idea that its futuristic war
attack makes it so much more fascinating
and terrifying no wonder then maybe that
Roger was laughing when he learned the
true history about a time when you could
fly to the moon heal all diseases and
change the face of the planet itself I
mean joyboy most likely explained how
all that knowledge and Technology would
one day come back once the right
conditions are met so no wonder that
Roger wished that he was born in the
same technologically advanced era's
joyboy and no wonder that he and his
crew were too early the Knowledge and
Skills of this Advanced civilization
were lost and would only return at a
certain point in the future and it of
course also really nicely explains why
the world government and emu have
technology that no one else in the story
has like the ability to eradicate an
entire freaking Islands they got got
their hands on the pieces of technology
that they wanted to secure for their own
rule from their enemies which does back
the third question here how in the world
did a kingdom with this level of
knowledge crumble in the first place the
only thing we know for a fact really
about the end of the Void century is
that 20 countries gathered together to
defeat the Ancient Kingdom these
countries would later on become the
celestial dragons who are secretly being
ruled by the mysterious emu but if
joyboy and Cole were as powerful as they
seem to have been well how did they lose
one explanation my new assistant here
tells me is that just like any other
Empire in history no matter how long it
lasts at some point it starts falling
apart from the inside like numenor in
Lord of the Rings a country that got so
wealthy and comfortable in their
position that they just start having
infighting and Corruption gnawing away
at its former glory so maybe emu and the
20 kings were actually allied with or
part of the ancient Kingdom and backstab
joy boy like Caesar gut for example
another option is that the kingdom
wasn't the only country with advanced
technology maybe the war was a conflict
like we know it from Star Wars where
both sides have access to terrible and
advanced weapons or there's of course
also The Wheel of Time option where the
civilization becomes so Advanced that
they discover something that they
shouldn't have an external Force even
greater and more powerful than them so
maybe the devil or devil fruit
technology was the thing that allowed
the government to wage war on the
kingdom a new power to match Joy Boys
and this would be a really nice
explanation for emu someone who offered
the celestial dragons his help while
secretly taking the throne for himself
ruling from the Shadows where he's able
to still rely on his own ancient
technology like the one that destroyed
God Valley and La Lucia which means that
for item number four on our list we have
to talk about all the things in the one
piece world that have hinted at
technology capable of shaping an entire
plan planets like the actual one-piece
Planet itself anyone who has seen the
layout of the globe knows that the world
of One Piece feels incredibly artificial
the grand line and the red line meet at
a perfect 90 degree angle and thus split
the world of One Piece into four equally
sized regions overlooked by the ruling
Celestial dragons on top of the only
consonant in existence the red line is
impossible to cross since flying
technology seems to be actively kept
from emerging while the grand line with
its dangerous and unpredictable weather
and currents and the windless calm belt
around it guarded by the Sea kings make
it impossible to cross it by ship and
the rest of the world seems to have been
flooded so that the only inhabitable
places are islands and this results in a
population that can't form any larger
groups or travel and learn about the
world which of course is designed to
keep people from rising up against the
government or learn about things the
government doesn't want them to learn
about all these weird anomalies like the
existence of Sky Islands or the giant
hole under Anna's Lobby we originally
thought that it might have been devil
fruits who shaped the world in this way
but now that we know just how advanced
the ancient Kingdom really was it seems
much more likely that actual technology
or Weaponry was used to terraform the
planet into a place that is easy to rule
and control
I mean just think of NL and his findings
on the moon the fact that he found the
plans for an actual spaceship in
shandora and that he encountered space
pirates were always really odd things
but now all these things are suddenly
closely tied to the void Century there's
technology there and an army of robot on
the moon that is powered by electricity
we have the giant Arc Noah a ship big
enough to carry an entire civilization
waiting to be used again and as we know
the technology in one piece overall is
all over the place on the one hand you
have spaceships and Laser Technology
While most people seem to be stuck in
the 1700s fighting with swords and
cannons modern steel warships While most
people Sail on wooden ones video live
streaming while the rest of the world is
stuck with paper and curiously enough
right Gojo curiously enough all this
advanced technology seems to be
monopolized by one faction
in case I didn't tell you uh I have a
new assistant Gojo so for number five on
this list we have to ask ourselves what
does this reveal mean for vegapunk and
the government well one thing that the
story so far and the echid island arc in
particular have made very clear is that
Dr vegapunk doesn't seem to think very
highly of himself for instance he
describes Momo's devil fruit as a
failure and is clearly not very
impressed with his own work calling it a
place of the past now I really don't
think that anyone who can build stuff
like that like the things he has built
can be called anything but a genius but
it does seem like vegapunk has been
reverse engineering a lot of the major
inventions he's credited with from
technology from the void Century
something that understandably does seem
to really bother him he seems to be kind
of disappointed that he can't do what
the people 800 years ago were capable of
doing I mean even though Momo's fruit is
a perfect copy of kaido's it's just that
a copy not an actual new devil fruit
based on the winged robots seen on the
Moon by annal it seems like the Sira
theme and passifista were also based on
Ancient technology I mean they're based
on the research that was conducted on
Kuma and King who both seem to be
lunarians who were known as the gods who
lived on the red line possibly the
original people of the ancient Kingdom
the giant robots vegapunk has built
seemed to be based on the giant one that
Luffy has just found outside the
laboratory in other words all the crazy
stuff vegapunk has built is just a
fraction of what used to exist before
and it's also no surprise then that the
government wants to take him out really
badly right now it really does seem like
vegapunk might know more about the true
history and its powers than almost
anyone else making him the number one
threat to the government rightfully so
it seems as one of the six vegapunks
Shaka number one is in direct contact
with dragon of the Revolutionary Army by
the way if you're a bit confused by the
entire six vegapunk plus one one body
thing how it works and what each of them
is like well I did a whole breakdown of
them in this video right here that you
can go watch next if you like